bienvenue à la facture des iPhone 9 on
peut en trouver sur Marketplace qui Gigi
les packs mais attention plusieurs de
ces appareils sont des contrefaçons qui
ne valent à peu près rien mais qui
ressemble à si méprendre au vrai iPhone
regardez bien
l'iPhone c'est le téléphone intelligent
le plus vendu au pays il est à la fine
pointe de la technologie ou du moins en
apparence parce que ce téléphone est un
faux
c'est un bon four c'est sûr que c'est
pas iPhone les fraudeurs les ventes sur
Internet et les font passer pour des
vrais si on achète un téléphone sur
Marketplace le prix est trop bon pour
être vrai habituellement c'est un faux
nous avons joué le rôle du client qui ne
se doute de rien effectivement 2350 ans
pour s'utiliser l'argent des gens si
c'est un faux ça c'est mon problème
ça serait le mien si je l'achète
une habituée des produits Apple cette
infirmière à la retraite utilise
régulièrement sa tablette et son iPhone
j'ai un téléphone Apple 10 je voulais le
changer parce que j'avais des problèmes
avec le Son et j'ai été sur Marketplace
Marketplace le site d'annonce classique
de facebook madame Lavoie est attirée
par l'annonce d'un certain Jordy un
iPhone 13 pro max complètement neuf le
téléphone est scellé la boîte était
celle-là puis il m'a demandé 1100
dollars en boutique le même téléphone
coûte 1549$ plus les taxes elle pourrait
épargner 700 dollars
j'ai dit pourquoi tu le veux et dis mon
cousin me le donner moi je n'ai pas
besoin l'histoire avait de l'air
plausible
madame Lavoie sauve sur l'offre elle
accepte de rencontrer le vendeur
il sort le téléphone je l'ai pris dans
mes mains je les regarde des mais il y
avait la Corée j'ai dû prendre
ur puis elle le quitte pour se rendre
chez son fournisseur de téléphonie
je vais aller chez Vidéotron puis le
jeune homme ça fait trois quatre minutes
il est identique vous avez pas
un téléphone fraudule
madame Lavoie est tombée dans le piège
son nouvel iPhone est un faux et d'accès
de nous le donner pour savoir ce qui se
cache à l'intérieur nous allons
découvrir avec Tarek Safa propriétaire
de la boutique fixipro
c'est assez impressionnant c'est très
très bien fait mais il y a quelques
signes qui montrent que c'est un vrai
téléphone comme la caméra beaucoup plus
discrète sur le vrai iPhone que sur le
faux ou encore le flash jaunâtre sur le
vrai rose et blanc sur le four on
remarque aussi des erreurs de langue
comme ici en plus du français le texte
est écrit en anglais et même en estonien
sans compter les problèmes de logiciel
le App Store ne fonctionne pas le
tactile répond beaucoup mieux sur le
vrai et si on a un clavier Android
en louvrin le faux iPhone nous réserve
aussi des surprises il y a juste une
caméra qui est vrai et les autres c'est
des deux fausses caméras ils ont mis
beaucoup d'efforts sur l'apparence
extérieure et le logiciel mal intérieur
on peut voir très rapidement que ce
n'est pas un vrai iPhone j'ai pas vu
aucune différence c'est quand le jeune
homme se Vidéotron les a fait remarquer
il était chercher un téléphone à Paul
régulier
madame Lavoie n'est pas la seule à
s'être fait prendre à Montréal seulement
le service de police traite 175 plaintes
de faux iPhone par an le commandant
Steve Belzil est bien familier avec le
stratagème il dirige la section des
crimes économiques du SPVM
elle est stratagème de fraude iPhone ça
date d'environ 2017 qu'on a eu les
premiers dossiers rapportés c'est un
faux produit importé de la chaîne puis
cacao Canada sont dans les emballages de
Apple donc ça laisse croire à l'acheteur
que le téléphone est effectivement neuf
il faut iPhone peut coûter moins de 100
dollars et être revendu 10 fois le prix
j'avais été à la banque avant de partir
j'ai sorti 1000 dollars je suis toujours
un peu prudente mais là j'ai été
imprudente il sortait un couteau ils
sont tués un arbre ils sortent quelque
chose il est assis dans ma voiture ça
aurait pu mal vivre
c'est important de idéalement de pas
apporter d'argent content intégrer à
quelques occasions que les fraudeurs ont
voulu s'en prendre aux acheteurs pour
prendre l'argent vendre sur internet
acheter sur Internet vous êtes pas
étrangère assez pas du tout j'étais
forcée je me suis dit pourquoi tu t'es
fait avoir il faut dire que les
fraudeurs sont convaincants en navigant
sur Marketplace nous trouvons rapidement
le même modèle d'iPhone que celui de
Madame Lavoie un iPhone 13 pro max
flambant 9 affiché à 1350 dollars nous
suspectons que ça soit un faux la
vendeuse a créé son compte en 2022 ça au
gur mal donc on fait des échanges avec
les gens c'est de vérifier leur compte
existe depuis quand effectivement ce
qu'on marque c'est des comptes sont
relativement jeune fait qu'il y a pas
beaucoup d'activités pour beaucoup
d'amis elle nous explique que c'est son
père qui lui a donné l'iPhone en cadeau
et qu'elle n'en a pas besoin et elle
ajoute même qu'elle est heureuse de nous
aider souvent ce qui est amené comme
prétexte c'est que ils ont reçu deux
téléphones en cadeau et que dans le fond
lui en ont deux fait qu'il fallait
partir nous savons aussi que la boîte du
téléphone est fausse la couleur noire ou
black n'existe pas pour les iPhone 13
pro max on devrait plutôt lire graphite
nous donnons rendez-vous à la vendeuse
et filmons la scène à l'aide de caméra
cachée
c'est écrit sur la facture la numéro de
série
exactement le 29
donc ça vient prouver pour le futur
acheteur que c'est sa Concorde c'est un
produit qui vient de Apple la facture
que la vendeuse nous envoie est contre
faite et contient plusieurs erreurs je
vais vous dire quand même beaucoup
d'incohérences dans cette facture là ok
donc c'est pas une facture
parce que vous savez que vous avez un
faux en de vos mains en ce moment info
téléphone
et elle nous a bloqué sur Facebook de
son côté le fraudeur de Madame Lavoie
lui avait aussi remis une fausse facture
le type chez Vidéotron en fait remarqué
que le 54 c'est un S14
donc en fait une sorte de frappe c'est
une fausse facture définitivement ici on
a la facture de la dame qui a fait la
transaction
à Gatineau ce qui est quand même
particulier c'est le nom d'animaux c'est
un nom qui est ressorti dans une de nos
enquêtes on peut être en présence du
McDo madame Lavoie apporté pleinte à la
police elle a même appelé le fraudeur
qui ne donne plus signe de vie je suis
content d'avoir fait une déposition au
poste de police mais c'est un mille
dollars perdus j'aurais aimé mieux le
donner à une cause de charité que un
type comme ça
[Musique]
si vous pensez que Madame Lavoine
n'était peut-être pas familière avec la
technologie non non détrompez-vous les
jeunes tombent tout autant dans le
panneau que les plus vieux selon la
police alors un truc donner rendez-vous
à votre vendeur si possible chez votre
fournisseur de service sans fil ou dans
une boutique de réparation les fraudeurs
vont peut-être changer d'idées